today is the first of December so it's
time for another monthly update video
and in this one I'm going to talk about
what went on during november which by
far was the busiest month that i think
i've ever had since I've moved up here
to the Hudson Valley and what we've got
coming up in December which hopefully is
not going to be quite so so packed by
design so in November we just finished
up with a seven day you might call it
mini retreat called stoic week that was
run by the University of Exeter over in
Britain they they've created this week
long event called stoic week and they
have you know workshops and a conference
and all sorts of cool resources I
participated and so did my wife it was
kind of nice to do that together in
their online class and I got a lot out
of it you know despite being somebody
who has a pretty extensive background in
the subject again this is a great
recommendation for for them and I ended
up doing a series of seven videos as
well five of the ones in the middle are
about particular stoic thinkers and tax
and mostly centered on on the issue of
anger three of them fit into that and
then to a bit more broad and then I did
one about you know what was going on in
still awake and who are the Stoics and
what I was hoping to do and then I have
a final video where I talk about you
know the experience and how it was a
very productive for for me so that was
um you know that was one quarter of the
month essentially stoic week before that
we had another glimpses of existence
existentialism lecture at the kingston
library this one was on Albert Camus and
we had some really lively discussion and
putting a link to the video here what
was really cool about that one in
addition to having a great discussion
and a lot of fun was that not only did a
local French teacher come across the
river from Poughkeepsie and bring some
of her students with her we also had two
young men who drove from Connecticut to
come to the lecture so you know great
for for the series great for philosophy
great for the kinks of
library in my view we went out to lunch
afterwards got to know them and it was
quite nice i did a did a few new things
this month that were as far as genre
goes things I haven't done before the
past I did a radio appearance now I've
done internet radio appearances on a
couple different sites but I've never
done like a live in the booth radio
guest appearance and I did that for the
radio Woodstock one of the few
independent radio stations left in the
United States and I was on the Woodstock
round table so that was really a lot of
fun the host himself was a philosophy
major in in college so we had a good you
know 2025 minute segment of talking
about that philosophy and its role today
and philosophical counseling and things
like that and then I hung around and you
know we had some chitchat with some of
the other some of the other guests I was
also on theology matters discussing a
log esteem you know I've done quite a
few of those those shows in the past
punk rock philosopher brought out a
couple shows including one specifically
on stoicism using some some clips of
that I'd provided him of some
discussions that I had and then I also
did uh oh this is the other thing that I
hadn't done before I did a guest sermon
well actually now that I think about i
have done guest sermons but only in
catholic churches because my uncle's
would sometimes have me my uncle's were
priests they would sometimes have me
give a guest sermon back when they were
alive and that's a long time ago this is
for a united unitarian universalist
church in rock tavern and so that i came
in and i gave a talk about anger in
early Christian attitudes towards it the
other main event that we had going on
during november was world philosophie
des world philosophy day is a UNESCO
event that happens once a year also in
november this year it was on the 20th
and so I had my friend and colleague and
a great you know program
an entrepreneur Leandro Lima come on and
talk about this platform that he's
bringing out truth score which is a
really cool idea it's designed to model
and to allow people to engage in
critical thinking together on
controversial issues so you can see that
the video for that if you want to that
I've got that link there it was a pretty
busy month as well as far as working on
classes I'd been still working on the
player know existentialism class but I
didn't get as much done on it as i would
i would have liked i missed a few my own
deadlines in part because i'm doing more
for my mayoress classes because as it
turns out there's a much higher demand
for me as an online teacher than anybody
had expected so i'm working on a marist
class that begins this Saturday called
world views and values and for that one
I'm actually doing everything from the
ground up i'm doing a totally new class
it's not new text to me but they're new
to the students we're going to be
reading 10 classic and contemporary
philosophical texts that have to do with
nature of the human person society
reality in general and how the human
person is connected with it so
everything from Plato's Republic to
letter from a Birmingham jail you know
Martin Luther King's document there
might have some other King stuff in
there as well like the I have a dream
speech since that has some interesting
things to say about that as well and
everything in between so dick carts
discourse on method Russo's discourse on
and the origins of inequality mary
wollstonecraft you know the the rights
of women we're going to talk about all
sorts of really cool stuff on the way so
I've been putting a lot of effort into
that getting ready because that starts
this week and I've also got two sections
of a four week intensive ethics class
that starts a little bit later in
normally I would do one of these over
winter now I'm doing too so that's a ton
of students a ton of creating and I'm
getting ready for for that and that has
some redesigning as well you know I can
keep the same material but all the the
homework assignments have to be redone
so that their original and I keep it
fresh got to think of new forum post
ideas and you know that sort of work I
also been working with this platform
called and Theo's and that's a little
bit more oriented towards lifestyle
stuff and it's about living a full
healthy lifestyle and and the the
contribution that I'm bringing to that
because there's a lot of people that are
they like into coaching or exercise or
diet or you know some fairly new agey
stuff with it I'm bringing classic
philosophical resources to bear on
topics like how do you how do you
actually stick to New Year's resolutions
you know how do you understand your
anger so I've done one class with them
so far and I'm very pleased with you
know how it turned out so I'm going to
keep on doing more classes with them I
got I got a good you know a bit of
blogging done over November in pretty
much all of my blogs i think virtue
ethics digest or excess dno IDK samplers
existentialism updates which is for that
class what else the heavy metal
philosopher blog i was able to get some
things done in there so that that's kind
of good and i've been working on this
textbook proposal working on writing a
sample chapter that i'm still finishing
up this week and revising it so that
it'll be a book of specifically about
the good life and how students can
understand the different components of
the good life and different outlooks on
it using classic philosophical ideas but
sort of you know working their way
towards it from where we are in the
contemporary situation so that's that's
a lot of educational stuff that I've
been doing videos as you know i started
a new champ
the critical thinking logic and
argumentation channel and I've been
producing and releasing videos in that I
have 13 fallacy videos at this point
released and there's probably in that
series we've probably about got another
30 or so to come and then I'll start
working on some other material with that
the half-hour Hagel were halfway through
the introduction which is pretty cool
and with Plato I've been releasing these
core concept videos that I did on the
Phaedo so there was a lot of that this
month no existentialism stuff as I'd
hoped this month but you can only pack
so much stuff in and I've been releasing
videos at a rate of about one per day
for the last month so a lot of video
production a lot of work on my end and
I'm kind of getting a little tired at
this point so that's good transition to
December December we deliberately set
things up so there's less stuff going on
in part because you know you've got the
whole Christmas thing happening and this
is the time of year when as a professor
because of the marist classes I tend to
be pretty busy because we have you know
classes beginning in december at the
starter december then we have that
intensive ethics class over the course
of it which requires me to be you know
looking at stuff every day and doing
grading every day so we wanted to set
things up so I wouldn't be doing too
much speaking or other work that's
that's taking me away from that and then
I'd have enough time for friends and
family around the holidays so what do we
get coming up we have one talk coming up
next week at the unitarian universalist
church of the Catskills that is a
fundraising lecture for them i'll be
talking about rainer maria rilke a the
famous poet and his views about God so
that we'll see you know should be pretty
well attended it's going to be a great
lecture I've been looking at this
material for for a long time thinking
about this real case pretty interesting
when it comes to
views on religion and God and then the
twentieth of December we finish the
glimpses of existence with Gabrielle
Marcel that will be our very last in
that that 12-month series but we got
another 12-month series booked with the
Kingston library starting next next
january i'll tell you more about that
though in the december january video i'm
not going to dwell on that here this is
going to be a month r all i have to do a
lot of lot of class related work and so
i'll be doing a lot of online teaching
and developing content and i will be
sharing some of that content with with
viewers in various places some of it not
not all right away I'm thinking
particularly about video content because
I'm shooting a whole new set of videos
for this world views and values class
and each week the students are probably
going to have a good two hours worth of
video I'll probably break it up into you
know four or five videos to make it a
little bit more concentrated a little
shorter for them and eventually I'm
going to be bundling these together into
an online class that will offer through
a player know and offer the videos to
people in my channel and I will release
some of them this this month but not not
all of them in part because I've got
other plans for the video channel so I
should probably tell you about that I'm
going to to release less videos this
month and my wife and I have been having
a back-and-forth conversation about this
she's always rather worried that I'm
extending myself a bit too much enough
that she's you know good to worry about
that and I feel like look this is
something I'm good at something I've got
the energy to do right now let's let's
get as much of this done as I possibly
can and so we can meet somewhere in the
middle
and she was suggesting that i should
probably just do two to three videos per
week and that's actually probably the
smarter idea but I've got all these
things all these irons in the fire you
know the new critical thinking channel
the half-hour Hagel series these backed
up existentialism videos that I'd like
to get two more more play-doh stuff and
now the new class so we came to a
compromise that I will do four or five
videos a week and and release that which
is still you know quite a lot I suppose
so I'm going to be doing a lot of
critical thinking videos because I want
to get that channel filled out as a
resource for people we're going to
finish up Hagel's introduction to the
phenomenology this month so there should
be four videos coming out this month
with the Hagel more play-doh material
there's one more core concept or maybe
two core concepts that I need to to
release that I didn't get around to the
play-doh stuff from my current class
that I'm going to be starting this week
with students the new play-doh stuff
I'll release that and make that
accessible to you YouTube viewers and I
also people have been asking me to do
more of those self-study videos and you
know I I really need to get around to
doing that so I'm going to release one
later this month another plato
self-study video once you've done those
first six dialogues where do you go from
there one of the other places you could
go would be to some of the dialogues on
love and friendship and so I'll do
something about that um what else I'm
going to I'm going to try to keep up
with blogging maybe you know two or
three entries per month in each of the
blogs but really one of the things that
I'm going to be doing is carving out
more time for for reading and for for
writing and for spending time
connecting with friends and family
because you know living out here in New
York I have some friends locally but
most of my friends and family are
scattered all around so I really need to
spend some time with that and then the
last thing that we're going to be doing
is focusing on what's going to happen in
this coming year we're looking for
partners whether institutions or you
know organizations that would like me to
come in and give a talk we're already
getting things on the on the calendar
which is pretty cool if you're
interested in having me speak at your
you know your school your church your
group whatever it is why don't you
actually send me an inquiry Greg at
reason I Oh calm and we'll consider it
we do some of our stuff gratis you know
pro bono some of it we charge for but
that's something that I've been putting
a lot of work into it is something I
really enjoy so that's what's coming up
in December now that I've actually laid
it out it's quite a lot not really that
much of a vacation but in comparison to
November kind of this so there you go